People are finally starting to
wake up to something crucial.
Something I've been talking about for years when
Republicans waged a war against so-called council
culture, when the right decries businesses
making decisions about what's best for them
because of backlash from the public, what they
are criticizing, what they are fighting against
is the very free market that they have
been defending almost to the death. I mean,
it's almost a religion for these people, the
free market. And they've been doing it really
since the reorganization of Republican politics in
the 1980s, this prayer at the altar of free market
capitalism. And this exposes a deeper truth
about the American right wing. Not only are
they short on policy, as we've talked about many
times. And not only do they simply play on values,
even the values they play on are only relevant
up to the point at which it becomes inconvenient.
What I mean by that is they talk about the power
and the efficiency of markets to guide economies
and cultures and countries. They say markets
are much smarter than government officials or
politicians. But then, as we saw this week, when
Dr. Seuss's publisher decides, you know, here's
six books out of a whole bunch, here's six books
that we're going to stop publishing because some
of the content doesn't really fit into what are
considered acceptable sort of social norms and
portrayals of minorities. Right now. That's a
free market decision made by a for profit company
because they looked at public opinion and they
said, let's make the decision that's best for
our bottom line. And Republicans instantly
throw their supposed values out the window
and spend three days. And probably it'll
be more talking about the travesty of Dr.
Seuss's so-called cancelation. So not only do they
abandon their supposed free market principles,
as soon as they don't like the outcome
dictated by the market, they also weaponize it
into the very outraged porn that allows them
to make money by covering this stuff on TV.
It's not new that they abandon their values when
it's inconvenient. This is just the latest way.
Think back when Democrats are in the White House.
All they talk about is debt and deficit and the
importance of balancing the budget. George W.
Bush comes into office, among other things,
give tax cuts to the rich and goes to war a really
expensive war with the wrong country and in so
doing, explodes the deficit. And they say nothing.
But then Donald Trump comes into office and then
cuts taxes for the rich, blows up the deficit
again, and they say nothing at all. And yet not
only do they abandon their values when it's not
convenient, they want to inject government into
it. When a market guides a decision that
they don't like and look at the trajectory
on this Dr. Seuss thing, we are for free markets
and keeping government out. This means you would
imagine businesses do what they want as long
as it's not illegal and the government stays
out of it. Dr. Seuss Enterprises, which made more
than 30 million dollars last year, decides here's
six books we will not continue to publish. They're
not canceling Dr Seuss. They're not burning books.
They're saying here's six books we will allow to
go out of print. But if you want to buy a used
copy, you can go ahead. And all of a sudden the
sovereignty of business to do what it wants to do
goes out the window. But not only that,
Republicans, including people like Jim Jordan,
the congressmen, demand congressional hearings on
council culture. Why is any of this the business
of the federal government? Where is Rand Paul as
a principled libertarian to say there is nothing
for the federal government to do related to this?
We should have no role here whatsoever. Hearings,
no way in hell. These are private businesses
making decisions however they want to make them.
They're not breaking any law. So quite simply, the
government should have no involvement whatsoever,
the market, as they like to say, should be
allowed to work its magic. If this decision
by Souce Enterprises is wrong, then the
market will take care of it, period.
If more people are mad about this decision
than the number that like it and they want to
exercise their ability to participate in free
market capitalism, they can say, well, I'm not
going to buy any Dr. Seuss books anymore. I'll
go buy whatever I don't even know, and then the
market will take care of it. This is their view
which they now are abandoning. But the truth is
that this has nothing to do with their stated
principles. What they mean by the free market
is a market that pushes society and culture and
institutions in the way they want it to be pushed.
They don't like the way that the market forces are
leaning right now in the direction of sensitivity
to racial and ethnic issues. They don't like it.
And that's fundamentally what this is all about
in this makes, you know, I've said before,
this movement that only wants to talk about
principles. Principles are a great place to
start. But when you only talk about principles,
you enter what's called the philosophical
black hole. And the really difficult work is
figuring out real world situations. This is
so so one part of the principles movement
that's bogus is that they very quickly abandon
their stated principles when the outcome isn't
what they want. But this is the other aspect of
it, that when you only talk about principles,
you end up with situations like this. They don't
like it. That's what this is all about. And
then this is also extraordinarily profitable for
many. And that's what I want to talk about next.